[Music]
foreign
YouTube channel today I'm covering a
story that blew my friggin mind I'm not
supposed to swear in the first 10
seconds to new rules on YouTube I'm
gonna read you the headlight front
assist who's rape like there goes the 10
seconds Thing Ray you get the point
whose lies drove the men to attempt
suicide is jailed for eight years CCTV
reveals moment serial liar bought Hammer
she used to beat her own face and then
she claimed she was the victim of an
Asian grooming Gang This is the the
woman right here 22 year old Eleanor
Williams here on the right is the
self-inflicted injuries and she's been
found guilty of perverting the course of
Justice earlier this year now before we
get into the details about how this
clown got herself caught it's important
to remember obviously
so many women out there actually have
this happen to them and are dealing with
it on a day-to-day basis and it is hard
enough for them to get believed without
clowns like this making it up and this
is the no point no no no one percent
this is the tiny tiniest minority but
unfortunately it ruins it for so many of
the real victims by putting elements of
doubt in people's heads and she is the
scum of the earth for that let alone
wrong wrongfully accusing these poor men
who've done nothing wrong so she accused
several men of raping trafficking and
abusing her in a Facebook post that
included graphic images of injuries she
claimed to have sustained the post was
made during lockdown in May 2020 and it
was shared more than a hundred thousand
times Spock National outrage leading the
dangerous racial unrest and a protest in
her hometown of Barrow in finesse
attempt attended by Tommy Robinson the
founder of the ADL three of the
wrongfully accused men try to take their
own lives [__] hell the level of
selfishness it's beyond anything that
you can even imagine this is where these
crazy [__] look at everyone as
collateral damage if I get what I want
if I get the attention if I get the
sympathy if I get the outpouring of
emotion from people that I am craving to
feel like I am important that I am
special if those men kill themselves
whatever it's irrelevant because she has
brainwashed herself so convincingly to
ourselves she has lied herself so much
that she actually probably believes it's
true at this point and it doesn't even
matter anymore it's the first time in
our life she's probably felt special and
that's all that matters [__] these guys
did they kill themselves so be it a
Curry House was attacked by Thugs and a
Muslim takeaway owner chased down the
street by men who poured alcohol on his
head this is probably a gang of people
who are thinking we're going to go and
get him obviously spurred on by This
Woman's accusations and I'm not taken
away from them they should never have
done that but like this is how one
person's crazy lies can have a knock-on
domino effect and this poor man's
running down the street for his life so
we've got CCTV footage here of her
buying the hammer which was later found
with her blood on after the injuries so
she inflicted all of that to herself
imagine smashing your own face and with
a [__] Hammer it's one thing to go
too far with plastic surgery it's
another thing to be like fancied a bit
of a change
that's crazy and then there's this it's
next level the judge said that there was
no explanation for her lies I mean I
disagree right she's a very ordinary
looking person I mean who gives a [__]
about her at this point I'm not going to
show any empathy the woman is the most
basic looking woman you've ever seen in
your life no man has ever looked at her
and thought wow I wish I could be
rehearsed someday let let's be real
she's the most basic and that's putting
it politely looking human you could ever
see the most unremarkable person and
that can drive someone crazy the
craziness in her is craving that
attention so desperately that she is
willing to take a friggin hammer and
smash her face in with it and then she
uploads it to Facebook why does she
upload it to Facebook when the judge is
saying there's no explanation there is
it's because there's a culture where
being famous is the goal for any reason
and we've created a culture where an
outpouring of emotion and sympathy and
you're a victim or bless you it must be
so hard
is a way to get famous now it's better
than being the most unremarkable bang
average looking girl you've ever seen on
the street in your life so for her
because she's crazy she's willing to do
whatever it takes this is two of the
poor guys who were roped into the crazy
mess this girl created 22 year old
Jordan was driven to attempt suicide by
baseless accusations and then this is
the restaurateur Muhammad ramzan uh who
she had claimed had trafficked her since
the age of 12. uh Mr ramsum denied any
contact with her it says here that
Eleanor Williams looks straight at the
judge and thanked her after he sentenced
her that's some dark [__] have you ever
seen monster it's a movie about the
first female serial killer basically
where she'd get the guys in the car she
was a prostitute and then she'd kill
them for the money and run off she had
this like deadpan didn't give it a [__]
Stone Cold killer about her this girl is
the chills up the spine type of woman
like [__] black widow life ruiner Mr
ramzan the business owner who was
accused of grooming her said he'd been
in it had his life made hell on Earth he
was in tears as he spoke from the
witness box said two weeks after he was
arrested following her claims he
attempted to take his old life
apparently him and his family were
targeted in the most horrendous ways had
the death threats made over social media
the young lad Jordan said that his life
was utterly destroyed and the word
rapist had been spray painted across his
house and his window was smashed in
after she had accused him so this lad
had actually spent 73 days in prison
where he shared a cell with a convicted
sex offender all on the say so of this
girl just boom there you go 10 weeks 10
weeks of your life and sharing a song
with a [__] sex offender boom easy as
another man Oliver Gardner said his
chance encounter with Williams in
Preston led to him being sectioned under
the mental health act Gardner who was
accused of rape after he met Williams in
the city center said it was a real shock
when he was contacted by the police and
told of her claims another man Cameron
Bibby was the first man to be accused by
this girl in 2017 said he had to remove
himself from social media because of the
online abuse and he was scared to call
him pick his son up from Nursery because
of the way people looked at him
apparently his neighbors had justice for
Ellie stickers on their windows
Jesus Christ man so Tommy Robinson and
all of them lot uh showed up basically
the protest the The Grooming gangs on
this girl's say-so and yet the funniest
bit about it is the girl actually said
she didn't agree with Tommy Robinson's
views as crazy as she is she still was
like I don't know if I'm that crazy
Tommy thought he was coming to the
rescue so in her most recent claim in
2020 she said that she was taken by a
gang to a house in town and raped but
the prosecution
um said that the injuries were caused to
herself by ahama the one which she was
shown buying there was blood found on
her Hammer close by what are you doing
sitting in bed [__] whacking it you
know what I mean it's this is not this
like she was also alleged to have sent
messages to herself making them appear
as if they were from traffickers or
fellow victims so she'd claim that Mr
ramzan the business owner who you're
seeing earlier had put her
um to work in brothels in Amsterdam and
then sold her at auction there but
unfortunately for her when she was in uh
the Dutch capital his band card was
actually being used at a B and Q in
barrel and when confronted with the
evidence she'd been with her sister and
her sister's boyfriend the whole time
she was in Amsterdam and the abuse could
not have happened Williams maintained
her version of events was correct she
saw sounds like someone who just watched
Taken and literally thought yep that's
me that this is about me so the
restaurant owner was actually arrested
himself over that and received more than
500 death threats online one man who was
accused by her had his wife leave him
over the claims while another family
were forced to move away from the town
altogether on another occasion she
accused the man of threatening to kill
her unless she had sex with eight men in
Blackpool there was CCTV showing she
booked herself into a hotel and then
stayed inside apart from a brief walk to
the shops never happened when she
accused that young lag Jordan of of
raping her he was actually cleared
because it turned out he had actually
been in the back of a police van at the
exact time he was supposed to have raped
her because he'd been arguing in a taxi
rung and spotted by police officers so
he literally couldn't have done it
evidence that she'd post it on social
media including messages from Men Who
who were alleged to have abused her were
found to be misleading or outright false
by police oh it gets worse she'd also
already pled guilty in an earlier
hearing to one count of perverting the
course of Justice which related to
contacting her sister and mother
requesting them to take a hammer to a
solicitor get rid of the evidence and he
has the real kicker this is her mother
Alison Johnston a 51 year old labor
counselor in Barrow and she is claiming
her daughter after all of that is still
telling the truth and this is exactly
why this sick this [__] happens when
you've got a parent who no not my
daughter no she would never tell a lie
that's how people grow up to be like
this when you've got an enabler who will
Buck you no matter what crap you talk
this is why this sort of [__] gets gets
to the degree it does in a number of
cases her claims like the innocent man
being arrested by officers who took
these appalling allegations seriously
what that means is these men would not
have been trapped well by coppers and
yet they were innocent so imagine how
rough that was for them bloody hell the
cops basically found that Williams had
not only lied but had concocted evidence
to support her allegations including
creating fate Snapchat accounts and
inflicting injuries on herself well I've
tried ending my life over it I've had a
bond with my son I've not been able to
leave the house I've not been able to go
to work you know so it's just now I know
she's locked away for a bit longer it's
just a bit of a relief but I wish it was
longer a sentence this kid will never be
the same again you think about this
right a woman's tried to do that to you
how are you going to trust anyone after
that it's insane for the loss of the
years the impact on my family here we
are and the true impact but that this
will love on true victims well said mate
I'm not sure how my family and I
we're going to recover from this for the
family we remain strong and we will be
strong
and we're determined to move forward
positively with our lives I feel for
this guy you know this is just an
ordinary restaurant guy mining his
[__] business and then this woman
just rips his life to shreds and you can
tell by the way he talks he's just a
gentleman I think what what she tried to
do the damage she did they should never
let her out that's how dangerous this
sick [__] really is let us know what you
make of this in the comments below I
want to cover more stories like this
weird interesting and crime-related
stories so if you've got any let us know
what you think in the comments below of
what I should be covering thanks for
everyone for all the support on the
channel don't forget to hit that like
button stay subscribed to the true
Geordie YouTube channel and I'll see you
on the next one